Five identical notes, all reading "Are you
sentient?"
were written and copied by Dr. Veritas in
preparation for the experiment.
A note was placed on the setting "Fine," and
produced a note containing an excerpt from
the 1641 treatise 'Meditation on First Philosophy’
by René Descartes in Latin.
It read: 'I am, I exist, whenever it is uttered
from me, or conceived by the mind, necessarily
is true.'
The next note was placed inside on the setting
"Very Fine."
What emerged was an excerpt from the essay
'An Essay Concerning Human Understanding'
by Philosopher John Locke reading: 'This Source
of Ideas, every Man has wholly in himself
… And though it be not Sense, as having
nothing to do with external Objects; yet it
is very like it, and might properly enough
be called internal Sense.'